I love a little drama level of faked
here how do you do that what places you
have to go to you just like it's like a
common situation I don't really like
focus think of something sad like that
single tear situation always that
everytime walkabouts come with me
joshing paste and today we are joined by
zendaya
now I loved this film it was sort of
lifting but they dot they're both did a
really great job right really fun they
killed it killed it what's your favorite
song in the bill what's the one you're
gonna play when you're down it's very
like inspirational and it's about you
know finding out the truth for yourself
and going out there and really
appreciating all the little things in
life which is which is a great message
so we're gonna play a game view called
be more Scindia okay good I don't have
some first world yeah T problem okay but
I want you to help me solve are you
ready okay so there is a journey of
self-discovery into the unknown
yeah when you've had south doubt what
have you told yourself discover the
voice began really good um I don't know
I I think I always like to remind myself
that my gut instinct is always the best
one I think often like we let too many
voices get in our head and too much
doubt too much fear and like all these
different things I think sometimes you
just listen to that like immediate like
gut reaction to something it's usually
the right feeling and you should just
try to follow that as much as you can if
it doesn't feel all the way right don't
do it it's like that old school
Christina Aguilera song voice within she
was on to something now what is the best
way to get yeah tea on my dance moves
what's like a good like Yeti move I
could do my character personally does a
lot of twirling yes she does it's like
her thing she's just like a nice little
and like every other scene I love it
I live for it so in that fabulous My
gods
braid the braid situations their best
life so yeah now the performance isn't
this are pretty amazing when it comes to
musical numbers and I also want to up my
like karaoke game what performance tips
could you give me um just lay the
competition we're gonna do karaoke I
always pick a song that you actually
know all the words to already so if you
want to like look away from the screen
you can you know what I mean if you have
to read it every single line that's not
the one for you you can't get you can't
deliver a good performance that way
make sure you already know the song
what's who go to karaoke SOG amazing
Michael Jackson usually I have all the
lyrics down to that stuff yeah or
Beyonce like any Beyonce song literally
the love everything is love like learned
all the lyrics within Ice Ice Baby that
was amazing
[Music]